With the weight of a nation on his shoulders, 29-year-old Hideki Matsuyama...
...held on to win the 85th US Masters in Augusta, Georgia, on Sunday,...
...making history as the first ever Japanese man to win a major.
Matsuyama, who started the day with a four-shot lead over a quartet...
...that included playing competitors Xander Schauffele...
...and Masters debutant Will Zalatoris,...
...carted a 1 over par 73 that left him at 10 under on the week,...
...at the year's first major.
American Zalatoris, a 24-year-old,...
...who is not even a full-time member on the PGA Tour,...
...finished in second place at 9 under...
...after shooting a 2 under 70, and Schauffele came in third.
Matsuyama grew emotional after becoming champion...
...and told reporters he was thinking about his wife and young daughter in Japan...
...on the day of his victory.